OK. Let's settle down.
Settle down. A couple of
announcements.
You got the test back.
This is what it looked like.
These are the very nice Gaussian.
You see it goes up and down. And
the average was 54 with a standard
deviation about 15. We
have a high here of 95.
We had a number of people in the 80s
and 90s. We had a number of people
that were in the 50s and 60s on the
first test who moved to the right,
and we had also some people that
were up here who moved to the left.
Far more moved to the left than
moved to the right.
I talked to the TAs and we put a
fair bit of care into preparing the
test that no one felt that it was
atypically difficult.
But somehow people didn't do as well.
I have been getting emails from
people asking about a makeup.
Yeah, there is a third test on the
17th of November.
We are not going to allow you to
retry until you get a score that you
like because there is no point in
doing that. You know what the rules
of engagement are. I don't
ask much of you.
But, if you fail to give seven hours
a week, you are not going to pass
this class. There was nothing there
that was out of the ordinary.
Nothing tricky. Just asking you to
answer a few skill-testing questions.
I am very happy to talk to anybody
about his or her performance.
I know my TAs are willing to do the
same. We have tutorial assistance
available at no charge,
but there is no substitute for your
making the investment in time.
And I think that perhaps some people
are lulled into complacency because
I don't require you to hand in
monster problem sets,
because I think that is childish.
I think that you should take
ownership of your learning.
I treat you as adults. But if you
think because I am not there looking
over your shoulder whether you are
doing your work or not,
I don't have to. I just look at
this. I would warmly recommend that
if you want to pass this class,
and I told you everyone in this room
should pass this class.
I want to fail nobody.
But if you don't demonstrate basic
proficiency, I cannot do it.
It is intellectually dishonest on
my part. You wouldn't want that.
You want to know the truth, so I
will tell you if you are not doing
the basics. And we will have a
chance to get back into the swing of
things. There will be
a quiz on Tuesday.
And I goofed. I issued two problem
sets in a row both called Homework 7.
Just to be clear,
I fixed this one and reposted it on
the Web. It is the same questions,
but basically you will be looking at
the x-ray diffraction questions and
the questions on defects.
That is where we are going to be
for Tuesday. And that is good news
because, those of you who had
trouble on the test this past
Wednesday, we are going to be moving
into some new topics so you get a
chance to start over.
Towards the end there is some
integration, but at least it is not
so strictly lock step that if you
didn't do well on Wednesday then you
are hopelessly behind.
Again, I mean it when I say this.
I want everyone to succeed here,
but you have to invest.
You have to invest. Last day we
were looking at defects.
We looked at point defects and line
defects.
Today I want to continue and look at
surface defects and volume defects
and ultimately go to something that
is so defective it lacks order.
We will move from surface to volume
to disordered solids.
Let's look at what makes surfaces
special. What makes surfaces
special is that the coordination
number is different at the surface
from what it is inside the material.
What I am showing here is the free
surface of the material.
And here is one region of the
material where the atoms are lined
up in this manner.
And here is another region of the
material where the atoms are lined
up in this manner,
because they grew from the melt
starting from different starting
points from different nuclei.
And, when they impinge, this plane
does not line up with this plane.
And there is a boundary along here.
We have two types of surfaces here.
We have a free surface and we have
an internal surface.
I am going to talk about both of
them. The thing they have in common
is that if we look at an atom down
here in the center,
if this is an FCC structure,
an atom here in an FCC structure has
12 nearest neighbors.
An atom here at the free surface
cannot have 12 nearest neighbors.
It has fewer than 12 nearest
neighbors. And we know that systems
form bonds maximally to
lower their energy.
Therefore, if I have fewer than the
maximum number of bonds,
this is not at as low an energy at
the free surface as it would be were
it inside the material.
Because at the free surface it has
fewer than 12 nearest neighbors.
That means that surfaces are higher
energy. They are higher energy
regions in the crystal.
And that can be good or it can be
bad. If we want something high
energy that is good if we are
looking for catalysis.
We will talk about catalysis later,
but catalysis occurs at the free
surface. By definition,
you need to have those broken bonds.
Catalysis is good, but it also
means things are highly reactive
sometimes undesirably.
And that can lead to corrosion
which is undesirable.
Where is corrosion going to occur?
This material is not uniform in its
properties. The corrosion
resistance of an atom deep inside
the crystal is different from the
corrosion resistance on the free
surface, which is different from the
corrosion resistance along this
internal surface.
Each of these regions is called a
grain. The grain is a virtual
single crystal. It is
a single crystal.
We have a polycrystalline material
consisting of a tapestry of single
crystals called grains.
And this internal surface is called
a grain boundary.
Both of these are defects.
What does the grain boundary do?
Well, the grain boundary does
several things.
First of all, the grain boundary
acts as a trap for impurities.
That can be good or it can be bad.
If all the impurities collect at
the grain boundaries,
and those impurities embrittle the
material, it doesn't matter what
ductility the grains have,
the material will fail at the grain
boundary. It would be as though you
had bricks that are very strong held
together by a weak mortar.
The grain boundaries act as that
mortar, but they have beneficial
effects. Imagine a dislocation
sliding in one grain.
It wants to rip through the entire
material. That misregistry of atoms
at the grain boundary stops the
dislocation so it can act as a site
for arresting dislocations.
It arrests dislocations. I talked
to you last day about the management
of defects. If we want to have a
material that has high strength and
is not going to easily slip,
do we want a material that has
coarse grains or fine grains?
We want to have fine grain material.
Grain boundary engineering is
important in the management of the
mechanical properties of material.
And I want to show you several
things. First of all,
here is a cartoon just to get you,
again, onto the page of what is
happening. These different grains
began from the melt at different
sites in the liquid,
grew to impingement. And you can
see these atoms cannot ever
perfectly align with the atoms
growing from the adjacent grain.
And so this zone of misregistry,
it is the void here which is called
the grain bound.
Now, this is showing it in terms of
cross-hatching.
The cross-hatching is tilted in
different ways.
And the gaps between the
cross-hatching are termed grain
boundaries. This is a piece of
polycrystalline copper that has
actually been polished and then
etched. And because their different
grains are presenting different
crystal densities,
atom densities, these grains etch
differently.
They etch at different rates in the
same acid. And,
after a while, they will actually be
tilting at slightly different angles.
And then when we illuminate this
with polarized light and look at it
under a simple optical microscope we
see different colors.
And these are the different grains.
Each one of these you can consider
a single crystal that has just the
normal atoms in their FCC lattice
throwing in some vacancies
and some dislocations.
And now they impinge along these
different boundaries.
And this is a field ion microscope
image of a tungsten bicrystal.
And right along the lower right
corner you can see the edge.
This is the grain boundary, so
there is a single crystal to the
lower right and the rest is a single
crystal to the upper left.
Grain boundaries. And also I can
show you again,
we will go to the document camera
and go back to our pal the atom mix
here and see if we can zoom in.
That is too much zoom.
Now auto focus. Auto focus off.
Auto focus on. That's a so-so auto
focus, but if we had a manual.
Oh, that's better. Now you can see
how things align.
You can see zones here,
perfect, and then you can see there
are some vacancies.
And you see along here?
These atoms are moving sort of
towards 2 o'clock and these
atoms are moving here.
And then, when they try to align,
there is the grain boundary. That
auto focus is really going nuts.
Isn't it fun to see the machine
struggle? I just laugh.
Laugh at it. It is a stupid
machine. Look at this.
There are grain boundaries,
and then the free surface up here of
course. These are both high energy
regimes. And we can anneal this.
If we anneal it we can try to get a
more coarse grain structure.
Now I have a single grain.
There was the original grain
boundary, there was one in here and
now we have a larger regime.
Let's go back to the computer.
Now let's look at three-dimensional
defects. Three-dimensional defects,
there are really two types, being
and void, things that are missing
and things that are there.
So, what is there and void.
I will talk first about the
three-dimensional voids.
Voids are simply coalesced
vacancies. The vacancies will
eventually come together and
coalesce. And so this clearly
weakens the material mechanically.
Mechanical properties are degraded
by the presence of what looks like
blowholes on the micron scale.
And then there are three-dimensional
defects consisting of matter.
And the most injurious is called
the inclusion.
And the inclusion is simply trapped
foreign matter.
It is trapped foreign matter.
Why is it trapped? Because it is
insoluble in the parent matrix.
And this can lead to deleterious
mechanical properties.
And I will show you an example
immediately following.
And then there is a desirable form
of three-dimensional defect which is
called the precipitate.
And the difference between the
precipitate and the inclusion is
that the inclusion is never soluble.
The inclusion is something that is
foreign matter that got trapped
during the melting process or the
vapor deposition process when the
solid was formed.
The precipitate sometimes is put
there by designation.
It is something that was dissolved
at one point and then made to come
out of solution,
so it is exsolved matter,
formerly dissolved. And the reason
that both of these are so injurious
is that they represent
separate phases.
And what do we have at the interface
between one phase and the other
phase? Well, we have the same issue
as an interface.
Not only do we have the bad
mechanical properties of the
precipitate or the bad mechanical
properties of the inclusion,
but we also have an interface.
These things do double injury.
And the other point is that most
typically the exsolved material or
the inclusion has a
different density.
And so when it comes out of solution
there is a volume change.
And that either leads to a
compressive stress or a tensile
stress. There is a volume
difference with the parent or the
host matrix. This all leads to
trouble. Now,
I showed you that carbon in iron is
strengthening the iron to make steel
because it is a little bit larger
than its interstitial site in iron.
And there are examples.
When you fly on an airplane,
you're flying on something that is
largely made of aluminum.
And one of the elements that goes
in there is copper.
And it goes in at a level that
causes precipitation of aluminum
copper compounds called
Guinier-Preston zones.
These are precipitates that raise
the strength of aluminum beyond what
you would have if you had
essentially pure aluminum.
You do not want to be flying in an
airplane made out of something that
has this level of ductility.
I mean, I love dislocations,
but there is a time and a place.
We don't want that. Let me show
you an extreme example of what
happens with inclusions.
Yes, the Titanic sank because of
these three-dimensional defects
called inclusions.
And this is some data taken recently
down at the National Institutes of
Standards and Technology in
Gaithersburg. This is Tim Fecke who
is a metallurgist who did a lot of
the work. This is a rivet.
And you can see the actual size of
it in his hand.
These are very,
very large rivets.
And these are the rivets that were
in the hull. What has happened is
they have cut the rivets,
polished them and put them in an
optical microscope. And
here is what you see.
If you look inside,
you see these dark zones.
These dark zones are inclusions of
slag. And how did they get there?
Well, in those days, we're talking
around 1910. The way steel was made
was in a unit called the open hearth
furnace. And the open hearth
furnace was the invention of Siemens,
one of his many inventions.
And the way the open hearth furnace
works --
This is not to scale.
What I am going to show you is a
vessel that would have a floor about
the size of the entire front of
10-250. Actually,
many times larger. But this gives
you a sense of the scale.
And you have two layers here.
Two liquids that are insoluble in
one another as salad oil and water.
The lower layer is iron, it is a
metallic layer,
and the above layer is slag.
And the slag basically consists of
things like silica, calcia, alumina.
It is all oxides so it is sort of
the equivalent of what you know to
be window glass or bottle glass.
And it lies in a giant pool on top
of a pool of metal.
And what is going on in here is
that the iron has come out of the
blast furnace,
it contains far too much carbon and
it contains impurities,
things like silicon and manganese at
too high a level.
And the process was called open
hearth steelmaking.
You had a vessel about the size of
the front of this room.
And, to keep it molten at 1300
degrees C, you had to giant burners
at either end.
And these things would be like
dragons shooting flames across and
keeping everything molten.
It was all contained in brickwork.
And the idea here is that over time
the impurities will rise out of the
metal and move into the slag layer.
For example, carbon in the iron
will react with some oxygen in the
iron to form carbon monoxide
and bubble away.
But, more importantly,
things like manganese in the iron
will react with oxygen in the iron
to form manganese oxide which is not
soluble in the iron,
and it goes into the slag.
This process, in those days,
took about 12 hours. For 12 hours
you kept the steel sitting at about
1300 degrees C.
And you want good mixing so there
is a far bit of turbulence here.
And, towards the end, you stopped
the turbulence and let
things separate.
Just as after you have shaken salad
dressing. You have oil.
In an aqueous phase vinegar.
And then you watch. Slowly the
bubbles start to rise and so on,
the globules of oil. Well, clearly
what happened on the day they made
the heat for this vessel,
rivets, somebody got greedy and
tapped the metal too soon.
With the result, there was still a
lot of this glassy slag-like
material in the metal.
Then the ingots were poured.
And then from the ingots they made
the rivets. Well,
when they make rivets they draw them.
And so, instead of having little
globules of glass,
which would have been bad but not
super bad, by drawing them,
can you see from the center of the
rivet, these globules have turned
into long stringers.
Now, instead of having the strength
of steel across the cross-section,
it is as though you have these
perforations. If you cut the
cross-section the other way and look
down, it would look like mortadella
luncheon meat.
There is meat and globules of fat.
That is what this thing would look
like. And then down here at the
bottom, see, there are stringers
everywhere. Now,
this thing does not have the
strength anymore.
When it hit the iceberg,
what should have happened is that
there would have been damage in the
hull in that local region,
it would have been taking up water,
and there would have been time for
five or six hours before the rescue
vessels arrived.
Instead what happens was these
rivets were so weakened by the
presence of the inclusions
that they broke.
But, as they broke,
it was just like a zipper unzipping.
It just went down the entire hull,
opened up, water rushed in and the
vessel didn't last very long.
It stayed afloat too short a time.
And, of course, there were not
enough life vessels on it and so on.
You know the rest of the story.
Anyway, it started with a bad
metallurgical heat which gave us the
trapped foreign matter which is
insoluble and so on.
Before leaving,
this is pretty much the catalog of
defects, I want to return to
something I hinted at last day.
I want to be clear with you about
the chemical origins of mechanical
behavior. And this is a part of 3.
91 that sets it apart from a
classical chemistry subject,
because what we have been looking at
is how electronic structure informs
chemical bonding.
Well, that is no surprise.
You would expect to get that in
chemistry class.
But then chemical bonding informs
atomic arrangement,
and that is where the rubber meets
the road when it comes to mechanical
behavior. You have to know where
the atoms are.
I want to talk about deformation.
That is what makes metals in
particular so useful.
That is why they have been
historically utilized by humans
going back to prehistory,
because they have the special
property of ductility.
We can take them in the solid form
and have them change shape.
And the reason they can change
shape has to do with,
first of all, their electronic
structure which leads to metallic
bonding which gives us these cubic
crystalline arrangements.
And then we introduce dislocations
and things slip.
I want to talk about two types of
deformation.
First of all, I want to look at
elastic deformation.
And this is deformation that is
reversible. It is characterized by
its reversibility.
And the simplest way to define it
is strain. That is strain only
under stress. Release the stress,
the material relaxes back to its
initial state. Only under stress.
Or, if you want,
you could say displacement only
under the action of applied force.
And Hooke's Law applies for this.
And I want to show you the chemical
origin of Hooke's Law.
We saw, when we looked at the force
curves that defined the equilibrium
separation of two atoms,
regardless of the type of bonding,
that we could plot energy as a
function of interatomic separation.
And we find that we have some kind
of a repulsive energy up here and we
have some kind of an attractive
energy down here.
And we went through the strict
derivation for ionic crystals,
but analogous derivations exist for
other types of crystals.
And if we go through we find that
there is a minimum energy which
defines this r naught which is the
equilibrium interatomic separation.
And this is E minimum.
Well, I can keep going.
What I can do is look at the
derivative of that and show you
where you get Hooke's Law.
If I look at the derivative of this
then that will give me force,
because I know if I plot force which
is equal to dE by dr,
the derivative of the energy with
respect to displacement.
And right here about r naught you
can see that the curve is positive
slope to the right,
negative slope to the left and is
flat at the origin.
I am exaggerating this over a wider
range, but it is fair to say that
about r equals r naught,
F is linear in r. Well, doesn't
that remind you of this from physics
where you have a spring and you hang
a mass on a spring,
and that mass on a spring in a
gravitational field gives
rise to a force?
And you can look at the displacement
versus an initial displacement.
Here is an x and here is an x
naught with no mass.
And I think you have seen this.
You've seen that some constant
times x minus x naught is force.
That's Hooke's Law, that there is a
linear relationship between applied
force and the displacement of the
string. And that is the same thing
happening with atoms.
For a tiny force I get a tiny
displacement, for a larger force I
get a larger displacement,
and if I relax the force the atom
springs back to its rest position.
What you are seeing on a macro
scale here is what is being played
out at the nanoscale here.
Hooke's Law is related directly to
the linearity in the force curve as
a function of position.
And, by the way, here is how he
published Hooke's Law in 1676.
It was first published as follows.
That is Hooke's Law as he first
published it. This is an anagram
and it is in Latin.
Hooke was a wise guy,
to be sure. He was a contemporary
of Newton. They hated each other's
guts. They fought bitterly.
Three years later he published the
solution to this, Ut
tensio, sic uis.
As the extension,
thus the force. He was quite a guy.
There it is. That is elastic
deformation. Now let's look at
plastic deformation.
Plastic deformation is the other
form, and that is permanent
deformation. Plastic deformation is
permanent. Let's look at the
chemical origins of that.
And now we will do another
experiment.
Instead of a spring this is a wire.
This is a wire and we hang a mass
on it. And this mass is very,
very heavy so that the force here is
great enough to actually cause
elongation. We have elongation of
the wire here.
Let's make this a simple copper
wire. It is pure copper FCC.
The only thing we have in there is
it has high purity copper.
There are vacancies, there are
grain boundaries and there
are dislocations.
Let's look at this a little bit more
carefully. Here is the wire,
and we are going to make it
polycrystalline.
I am going to indicate
polycrystalline as follows.
Different grains have different
orientations of the atoms.
And I am applying a force in the
vertical direction.
The question is how does this
deform? If we go down to the next
level, I will take a look over here
on the right side.
And I can imagine that I have here
atoms touching as follows.
It is in an FCC lattice, but I am
pulling in the vertical direction.
Now, maybe around the early 1800s
we might argue that the atoms start
off as spherical and then they
become elongated under
the action of a force.
But I think that is kind of goofy so
we are going to turn that one down.
Instead what we are going to do is
say, well, we know about
dislocations and we know that
dislocations allow atoms to glide
over one another.
So what is the problem here?
The problem is that the atom planes
are lined up on a 45 degree angle.
What the system does is it reforms.
It reconstitutes the applied stress
and resolves it into a resolved
sheer stress that moves along the
componentry of the atoms.
What happens is this atom plane
underneath slides down to the lower
right. The next plane slides to the
upper left. And,
from a distance, we see that the
wire is becoming narrower and longer,
but it is happening thanks
to the atom slip.
And we went through the reasoning
last day of what the slip systems
will be. The atoms are going to
slip in such a way that preserves
the strength of the planes.
The planes that will slip over one
another are the planes that have the
tightest binding.
And the tightest binding comes from
neighboring atoms.
The planes that have the tightest
binding are the planes that have the
highest populations.
That would be the planes of highest
packing. We have gone through this.
And just to return. The planes
that have the highest packing are
the ones that have the highest atom
density, and that is going to be the
highest binding.
The highest density plane in FCC is
.
And then the plane will slip along
the direction that has the highest
density. Because what we are
thinking of are rigid rafts and
rigid rods. To make the most rigid
raft you have the highest density of
bonds. And once you are in the
plane, how do you slip?
Are you going to push a wet noodle
or are you going to push something
that is rigid?
The highest rigidity comes from the
direction where the atoms touch.
And so all of this goes back right
to the very beginning and explains
how slip systems work.
And so slip systems operate in
close packed planes along close
packed directions with the
aid of dislocations.
Which provide for the ability to
move in permanent displacement at
stresses that are less than what is
critical. Now,
what I would like to do is show you
something that comes from a bubble
raft model that was constructed by
Krystyn Van Vliet as part of her PhD.
She is now a faculty member
in our department.
This is a bubble raft model that
represents the movement of atoms
under an applied stress.
Let's look at the first one here.
What you are going to see is --
-- the application of stress,
you will see the grain boundary,
and then you will see a dislocation
here. And you will see the atom
squirt up. The force is being
applied from top to bottom but the
atoms are on an angle,
so there is a dislocation that
issues from this triple junction.
And now it is up in here and is
getting ready to squirt
up to this side.
You can see how the atoms are moving
side-by-side on a 45 degree angle in
order to allow for what,
in essence, has to be compression in
the vertical direction.
I will show you another one that
involves a single crystal and the
same thing. The pressure gets high
enough that finally a dislocation
originates in the center of a single
crystal, the dislocation shoots up
to the surface,
and now you have a step at the
surface.
Now we have a single crystal.
You are going to see a dislocation
originate right in here.
There it is. You see it squirt.
And now there is a step here. This
side of the surface is one atom step
higher. We will see it one more
time. It will originate right down
in here. There it goes.
The atoms are slipping over the
highest population.
Now you know the origins of
mechanical behavior.
Now I want to talk about the
ultimate defect, which
is total disorder.
And so what we are going to look at
is a loss of crystallinity and go to
amorphous materials.
I will take you back to the big
picture, which was about a week or
so ago, where we looked at how we
got to solids.
And we said there are two types of
solids. We saw that we have ordered
solids, and that is what we have
been talking about for
the last week or so.
And now I want to get over here to
disordered solids.
These are solids that lack
long-range order.
There is a little bit of
short-range order.
Amorphous solids. And the
colloquial word for them is glasses.
Amorphous solids or glasses. And
these are solids that lack
long-range order.
What kind of solids can form glasses?
Well, anything that is capable of
being solidified in a way that
prevents crystallization.
I can show you inorganic glasses
such as the silicates that sank the
Titanic and are also used in
everything from window glass to
beverage containers and so on.
These are made of SiO2,
and we are going to return to that
as a prototypical system to study
very shortly. There is organic
glasses, the most common being
polymers. For example,
the polymethylmethacrylate that we
use in such applications as
substitution for window glass,
the polymethylmethacrylate you use
in your eye glasses,
this material is all disordered.
And we even have elements that have
certain features.
For example, sulfur.
Sulfur typically when it solidifies
does not form a crystal but rather
forms a glass.
It is an amorphous material when it
solidifies.
The point here is that we do not
classify things as amorphous based
on their chemical composition but
rather based upon atomic order.
And specifically here the lack of
long-range order.
And some do both.
For example, SiO2,
silica, silicon oxide.
If it forms a crystal,
we call it quartz.
And the quartz crystal in our
watches is made of high purity SiO2
which has been hydrothermally
processed to give it a high degree
of crystallinity.
And it has a very characteristic
vibrational frequency from which we
derive the ability to set the time.
But we can also have amorphous SiO2.
And this is the only time you are
going to see me use this term as the
general public uses it.
It gives you glass,
as you know glass. Window glass,
bottle glass and so on. But only
when I put quotation marks am I
using this vernacular,
this vulgar term. When I use the
term glass up here,
I mean no long-range order.
And so I think just to get some
nomenclature here so that you will
know, you have silicon which is the
metal. The oxide is silica, SiO2.
And the anion is silicate.
And so we will refer to silicate
glasses. SiO4 four minus is the
maximum coordination.
You can go through. You have
aluminum. Al2O3 is alumina,
AlO3 is aluminate and so on. I
thought, since it is Friday and
people are kind of in a festive mood
after the quiz on Wednesday,
I would take a look at the geography
here.
I think we can learn a little bit
here. This is Si.
I am going to now look at oxides.
This is silica, so this would be
Germania. GeO2 would be Germania,
which is Latin for...Germania. I
wonder what the Latin is.
How about Germany? Maybe Germany.
Gallium, the oxide is Gallia. What
is Gallia? France.
France lies to the west of Germany.
See, that is making sense. In 203
would be India.
India is south of France.
This is the oxide of Polonium,
so that would be Polonia. That is
Poland. Poland is east of Germany.
It is not south of India so it is
not so good. This is Francia,
which is France. So France is twice
on the table here.
We have got to do something about
that. This is Ruthenia,
which could be Russia, more properly
Ukraine.
Scandia, well,
it is almost Scandinavia,
not quite. Hafnia, hafnium was
discovered in Copenhagen under the
direction of Niels Bohr.
It was an impurity in zirconium.
Hafnia is the Latin name for
Copenhagen. Holmia is Stockholm.
Lutecia is the Latin name for Paris.
If you go surfing,
you go to Cf 3, California.
While we are on the Periodic Table,
copper is also geography. It is a
corruption of the ancient word for
Cyprus. Cyprus and copper have the
same root because copper was mined
in Cyprus. Strontium,
that comes from the Latin for
Scotland. That should cheer the
hearts of McDonald and
McTavish and so on.
Hesse is the province where
Darmstadt is located in Germany
where they have that accelerator.
So that's Hassium, Dubnium is for
Dubna in former Soviet Union.
And Berkeley is where we have the
accelerator in the United States.
If you had the oxide of Americium,
it wouldn't quite be America. It is
Americia. There is Europia.
Terbia. One town in Sweden is
called Ytterby.
And we get yttrium,
ytterbium, erbium and terbium.
Four elements from one little town.
What do you think is in that town?
There must be a resource of minerals
from which all of these elements
were discovered.
What else is up here?
People. Rutherfordium.
Seaborgium. This is Niels Bohr,
Bohrium. This is Elisa Meitner.
And now we have our pal Roentgen.
He looks like he is going to go on
111. There are Curies,
Einstein, Fermi, Mendeleev,
Nobel and Lawrence. E.O. Lawrence
was the designer of the accelerator
that was put at Berkeley.
That is why you have the Lawrence
Berkeley Laboratory.
There is astronomy here,
too. Did you see the lunar eclipse
the other night?
Tellus is the earth and Selene is
the moon.
The moon is above the earth.
That is good. Mercury is a fast
running planet and it is a liquid
metal. Pallas and Ceres are
asteroids. And there is the outer
reaches of the solar system,
Uranus, Neptune and Pluto. There is
so much information.
Can you believe it? Enough fun.
Now let's look at the conditions
that stabilize glasses.
And I am going to look at it from
the perspective of solidification.
Liquid goes to solid. And I want
to ask why something would decide to
solidify as an amorphous solid
rather than a crystalline solid.
And so there are basically three
factors to consider.
The first one is --
Let's do it in an analogy.
Suppose you were thinking about a
game that your younger siblings play,
musical chairs.
Musical chairs involve moving
around while music is playing,
and then there is a rush to get to a
certain site, a certain chair.
So the chairs are the lattice sites
and the people are the liquid in
motion. What is going to enhance
the ability to get to the lattice
site? In other words,
to crystallize? Mobility is an
issue.
Mobility of atoms in the liquid is
going to enhance the ability to
crystallize. What is another factor?
Well, the arrangement of the chairs.
If the chairs are simply arranged,
it is easy to get to them. If the
chairs have complexity in their
arrangement then it is more
difficult. Let's liken that to the
complexity of the crystal lattice,
complexity of the solid crystal
structure.
Systems that have complex crystal
structures are more apt to form
glasses than systems that have
simple crystal structures.
And then the last thing is how
you're told to race for the chairs.
Normally the music is shut off
abruptly, but suppose I had a turn
on the volume.
In some cases,
I turn the volume down slowly and in
other cases I turn the
volume down quickly.
That is your cue to start moving to
the lattice site.
And the analogous quantity in the
basic physics is temperature,
so cooling rate has an effect.
High cooling rates are apt to
quench in the liquid disorder.
High complexity of the solid is apt
to make it difficult to make a solid
crystal. High mobility is in favor
of crystallinity,
so I am going to replace mobility
with the analogous quantity so that
when all of these are high I do not
form a crystal.
The inverse of mobility,
at the liquid level, would be
viscosity of the liquid.
Highly viscous liquids that have
very complex solid state crystals
that are cooled very rapidly
will form glasses.
And we will look at that in a little
more detail next day,
but here is what I would like to do,
show you something very interesting.
And I said anything could be made
noncrystalline.
And the one I am going to show you
here comes from 1959 when somebody
decided I am going to make
a metallic glass.
And what happened here is Pol Duwez
at Caltech, not far from some of the
places we just looked at on the
chart, decided to cool a gold
silicon, drop the temperature down
very, very low where he could get
down to hundreds and hundreds of
degrees below the normal
solidification temperature,
put it on a water-cooled copper
wheel, cooled at a rate succeeding a
million degrees per second and
quenched in the disorder
of the liquid state.
So this is metallic glass.
This has no long-range order.
This is one giant amorphous mess.
There are no grain boundaries.
There are no grains.
There are no dislocations.
Listen to this.
It doesn't have the ductility of
aluminum. It is very,
very different. We will talk a
little bit more about that,
but I have to do something special
today because Sunday is Halloween
and I cannot have you all coming to
my place. Oh,
I forgot to show you this.
Somebody sent me this. Natalia
Cherenkov sent me this.
This was late in the game on
Wednesday. Did you catch
this? [APPLAUSE]
See, we are everywhere.
3.091 is everywhere. I am going to
show you some beautiful glasswork of
Dale Chihuly from Seattle.
And then what we are going to do is
do some trick or treating here.
Do you think we could dim the
lights a little bit?
I think it is a little bit too
bright for this sort of thing.
What we are going to do is share.
[APPLAUSE]
I don't want to hit one of those
cameras, though,
because I don't have insurance like
that. What we are going to do is
cheat a little bit and come up here
and throw some up this way and up
this way and up that way and over
there. Now, you have to open them
up and share. You're supposed to be
very group-oriented here.
And those who don't get any,
they're bad for your teeth anyway.
Who didn't get anything? Oh, you
didn't? Who is sharing here?
Come on. If you didn't get the
handout, raise your hand.
You guys got about four bags and you
are asking for more.
One last one. Where is it going to
go?
I've thrown about five bags up there,
so I am going to put this one and
you can share.
All right. Stay out of trouble
this weekend. I will
see you Monday.